[Music]
so you guys know that the fda
is ordering joule e-cigs off the market
good what you think it's good why is it
good the nba doesn't allow jewels
i thought you already can't smoke on the
cord or whatever
yeah yeah keep going
what are you talking about kobe get that
ring off your finger
jewels but yes no they won't let jewels
sing the natural animals
[Laughter]
why is only jewel being targeted
because jewel is the one that
specifically targeted kids in a way yeah
they were advertising to children like
all the flavors like bubble gum grape or
whatever like the kids wait what is a
jewel
uh a vape e-cigarette e-cigs you know it
looks like a usb oh yeah yeah yeah
very complicated i don't care about
all the asian guys and toyota supras
that are [ __ ] up their lungs but
they're okay with that i didn't see any
marketing directly to that demo yeah
dude there's a supras in general yeah
in 2022 supra mario
if you're a fat asian dude with a
[ __ ] like with the [ __ ] vape on a
on a ruckus scooter that's a demographic
that's a vape demographic bro yeah i
think that dudes are still smoking real
[ __ ] too
maybe but indoors they're smoking their
vapes supers they're smoking exhaust
baby let's tell you this though
i had no nobody told me how strong
[ __ ] uh thc is on like the vape [ __ ]
nobody [ __ ] told me that [ __ ] i got
blasted out of my heart
what did you do take a bong grip well so
jalil white has a company right
here john arkell yeah so he hit me up
and he sent me some stuff i was like oh
cool and i actually was smoking it here
on jk
right and so i took a couple of friends
which i thought was completely fine it
was no brand though i just like julia
white i think he's amazing his stories
are hilarious so i was talking that's
crazy hey you know what i'm saying
let's backtrack on that first did i do
that it's stupid
your eyes look a little red right now
take something
let's take something
so i actually hit it on jk news and i
only did half a day and this was a while
back and then as i was driving monsters
were chasing me
i was like what the [ __ ] and i started
getting the hell of speeding i was i was
[ __ ] the difference between
psychedelics and weed listen listen you
know what jew was hidden but if monsters
were chasing let me check it out i was
also drinking i got crossfaded i got
[ __ ] up i had no idea this happened i
got crossfitted accidentally twice in my
life and it happened from this [ __ ]
because i thought if i just hit it once
and i chill and i drink a little bit but
it's so much more potent and i had no
[ __ ] idea it's called a concentrate
well nobody told me all right
now he's getting [ __ ] by a monster
in my car driving oh god
[Laughter]
i go home i'm laying in bed and i'm
under the covers like this right and
then mariel comes up to me she goes are
you okay i go
i'm fine
are you high i'm like what makes you
crying like i'm tearing up right i don't
know why but i'm just like so high out
of my mind and then finally when i
realized i was high it kind of like
sobered me up a little bit because i
could rationalize what was happening was
that a good review for the product yeah
yeah
some of the best we've ever had
if you want to cry at home
hide under your sheets by monsters yeah
anybody nobody here has ever used the
jewel i i've hit one socially yeah for
sure are jewels more potent than they
seem to be or what with thc you know you
know what the reason
my personal thing about it is that the
thing is like let's say hypothetically
you smoke a cigarette right one there's
an action of needing to go to a place
that's accepted and then you have to go
through the physical thing of lighting
it and then when it's done and you smell
a certain way that is a thing you go and
carry on with yeah
the problem with vapes
is that you can hit it in like an indoor
spot disappears no smell easily
accessible people don't like into it
that's not a problem you can hit it and
people people don't think you just did
something that sounds good it actually
ends up making you want it it's almost
like you smoke five cigarettes and you
can hide
so it's way easier so the same thing
with even the weed with weed that's even
way crazier because that's less
exception than cigarettes we you used to
have to [ __ ] grind the flower put it
in a bowl a ritual smoke it in a [ __ ]
giant environment that wasn't going to
make me for a mile yeah and when you
when you smell like wheat everyone
judges you even more than cigarettes so
it was like people give you that thing
but then once they invented things like
the vape cartridges for weed that made
[ __ ] exceptionally dangerous because you
could get high and no one would [ __ ]
know and they have like actual studies
where they show that like like obviously
smoking a vape from a e-cigarette is
like quote-unquote safer than like
actual cigarette but because of the fact
that like what anthony said you can hit
it constantly yeah people are getting
more addicted to it and they're actually
like using it way more so the incidences
are increasing but they still don't have
enough studies to figure out like how
much they will yeah they will soon but
it's our generation when we all die off
they'll know some [ __ ] i got buddies
that they just started doing it and then
they just every time i see them they're
just constantly
constantly you're grappling with them
like no these are my non youtube buddies
and they're just
that's how with french fries dudes
that's what they said imagine if you had
french fries everywhere you went and you
just kept eating them
it smells so good i'm like is that
pomegranate what the [ __ ] is that if
that's the [ __ ] that that vape [ __ ]
right prior to covert i would walk into
that [ __ ] on purpose like they would
apologize they're like i'm sorry look
what you apologize is that snickerdoodle
it brings it back
what you apologize before you shot gummy
shotgun
do it again i'm out
that ain't gay stick it in here
see the vape because you're inhaling
them
those are my clowns
[ __ ] david's on the other side of the
vape like
you're on the opposite side are you
always high i just find people with
vapes
they got shotgun double-sided
people actually hypothetically get mad
at you that you're getting high off
their supply probably
like what's the audacity of that it's
like bro you're gonna blow to the air
anyways
you wasted it really i know the problem
get mad if you got high of my supply but
if i was like trying to exhale and you
went
that far
off
but i wasn't touching you though
yo we should do that as a guy
i'm not touching your dick i'm not
touching imagine nine dudes right we do
that as a group and we call it the vape
patrol right so we don't want any vapes
in the air so then we suck it up for
them so if someone's vaping we [ __ ]
run up to them and when he excels we
just all swarm up and start sucking up
the smoke hey hey anybody here from oh
this is my college days this is most
[ __ ]
bug gang ghetto [ __ ] when you couldn't
afford hella weed and stuff like that
and you would just try to take hits and
you try to share that what you would do
even with your homies is you would pass
the smoke the second hand high so you
will grab hand give me your hand dog
you'll grab hands like this and create
this shaft
and i'll go
and blow this smoke hey real quick hey
listen hey
and then you take the hand off i'm just
saying you're just kissing and then you
back out
nothing to do with me i met you later on
in my life because i would never have
been your friend
i thought it was serious hey let's just
say hello i'm glad i met you before and
after you had that tattoo on your shin
yeah hey i respect you but listen we're
going to turn back the time all right
we're it's you're 2 000. that's [ __ ]
gay
and now we're back in 2022. we're fast
forward to the times 2022 what'd you
think about shangshi
that's pretty gay
i'm just kidding i'm stopped
hey we're making jokes about time stuff
we don't say that now
it's straight that's pretty hetero bro
got some humor it's quantum that's
pretty acceptable yeah that's pretty
acceptable i think jules should be off
the market
i think for kids absolutely yeah
in general no for kids absolutely but
how can you avoid kids will never have
the joy of [ __ ] sucking on watermelon
smoke but you have to be 18 to buy one
don't you well yeah but as a product
aren't like aren't you trying to get
kids to buy this [ __ ] because it's who's
gonna be [ __ ] using them yeah but you
know what's happening now because
they're doing those mods with the
the vape stuff where it blows big smoke
that's now becoming the guy who did
magic in high school
you know
[ __ ] losers dude if you want to
create something tornado
hey watch this guys hey it's a ring
that should [ __ ] spit and [ __ ] too
yeah dude and then they do a video
saying why i can't get white women
jesus christ
well what if fda is ordering e-cigs off
the market because they're not buying
cigarettes anymore and they're just
buying these e-cigs
yeah maybe this is tobacco lobbying i
have no [ __ ] so the whole thing's
banned nobody can get it but then big
tobacco owns a large share of your pick
big tobacco is the [ __ ] evil dude
this should all be off the market but it
won't ever be like [ __ ] man how are we
gonna get people to smoke again yeah we
need them to get these reds but they're
gonna well aren't aren't some places
trying to make smoking just flat out
illegal like hope like places well in
japan um they have smoke free cities
isn't that [ __ ] crazy oh the whole
city
they changed a lot because you know
back in the day
no no no you can smoke in designated
areas so like there's certain cities
like uh
what's that one that uh has all the
hookers shinjiku i think i don't know
all right
i'll answer myself thank you there's
districts
i think this was like in the mid like
2014 or some [ __ ] but
when you're in a smoke-free city you can
only smoke in designated areas and it's
usually right outside of the trade
station but then used to be able to
smoke up and down the street everywhere
you can't smoke up in down the street
here's the countries where you can't uh
smoke in public at all norway new
zealand uruguay malta italy sweden
scotland bhutan lithuania and the
british italy you can't smoke in
probably italy that's [ __ ] i've seen
hella full of [ __ ] gondola [ __ ]
pilot was [ __ ] smart we're trying to
have a violence
you can't say pilot bars
[Laughter]
i do your plumbing and i find a mushroom
maybe it's one of those things where
like that's what it says on paper but
nobody observes it because of the
culture on his [ __ ] face here when he
said pilate was like
whatever you call it
a pilot
captain of the ship yeah
smoking is illegal it says you can't
smoke in a public place no that's
[ __ ] maybe italian's
italy's a private
i just i just pictured an italian guy
smoking in front of somebody don't smoke
it here
you